[Music]
justin bieber crushes the viral tick
tock trend to coila ray's twin um with
coyla ray i'm having a good time on
wednesday the 24 year old musician
posted this clip to tick tock getting
low one beat at a time with the biebs to
her hit track
coy captioned the clip by simply tagging
justin and adding a whole bunch of
emojis the song has taken the social
media platform by storm and the trend
it's simple
dance with your bestie
[Music]
earlier this week paris hilton and her
close pal kim petras had some fun in the
aerys closet
and current bachelorette michelle young
accepted the challenge alongside fellow
bachelor nation stars caitlyn bristow
tasha adams and serena pitt
[Music]
even cheech and chong got it on the
phone
but back to the biebs
yep the 27 year old ghost singer made
another appearance on koi's tick tock
playing the piano while she's sane
[Music]
of course justin has gotten pretty good
at using the social media platform back
in january he shared this time lapse
video in the hair and makeup chair
getting all his tattoos covered for the
anyone music video
[Music]
in february 2020 he documented the
moment he shaved his much talked about
mustache
be going through changes
and he was literally all of us during
quarantine amid the kova 19 pandemic
learning viral tick tock dances with his
wife haley why is everything chrome
and if you thought they were couple
goals there well just wait until you
hear what he had to say about haley in
his new documentary justin bieber our
world
i think in a lot of homes especially my
home growing up a lot of things were
unpredictable and so that just made
things
unreliable now that i have a partner to
be able to spend my life with it's been
really good for my mental health it's
been really good for my heart my spirit
and i'll send you off with an extra dose
of cuteness courtesy justin we could be
traveling all across the world and if
i'm with her then i feel like i'm home
[Music]